si reactivación del comercio
agroalimentario a cambio de levantar las
sanciones contra rusia es el órdago de
vladimir putin que ha presentado ante
occidente putin ha hablado con el
canciller alemán olaf scholz y con el
presidente francés en manuela macrón a
ambos les ha dicho que rusia está
dispuesta a volver a la mesa de
negociaciones de paz con ucrania pero
esta vez putin ha ido más allá y ha
dicho que está dispuesto también a
incrementar la exportación de
fertilizantes recordemos que rusia es el
exportador número uno mundial de este
producto básico para la industria
agroalimentaria incluso ha dicho putin
que mediante algún tipo de acuerdos se
podría hablar de que ucrania pudiese
exportar su grano desde esos puertos del
mar negro que ahora mismo están en manos
de rusia o están siendo estrangulados
por
marina rusa de manera que ucraniano
puede exportar